you are 46 why do you not have the
successful relationship and are you
dating someone
right now it took me five years to even
consider it
um because the one relationship that i
entered that i swore
was gonna work was the one with my kid's
father will
and that one when it couldn't and it
didn't
and we turned every stone over and we
did everything two humans can do
right and there was a lot of dignity and
grace but we
just have the north star of our kids and
we're in such a good place and it took a
long time to get there but we never
lost sight of what was important and we
never stopped
having this togetherness and i moved to
new york and i'm in it with him and his
family
and i'm happy to say he just got engaged
to this wonderful woman named ali who i
am
probably president of her fan club and
thank god
because she's face because she's going
to be around your kids
and so you getting the uh you you
feeling okay about that is is a good
thing no evil stepmother is the greatest
blessing i could have ever hoped for
she is just so wonderful i want him to
be happy
and honestly i could not have looked
elsewhere for anything
i wasn't open to it there was no room
this was the most sacred thing
i've ever entered in my life with these
children
and i couldn't do anything but honor it
and when people say you know you should
date
my response was it's not within me
and no one else can tell you when that
time is
it's like this natural progression and i
finally feel finally
just now free are you with someone now
it's been six years uh i'm assuming
you've been
celibate for six years that's a lot talk
about isolation
are you now ready been on some dates now
what is it like to date drew barrymore i
imagine a lot of guys
are intimidated they feel that you uh
yeah who are these days where did she
find them yeah where
because robin app
i fought it for the longest time the
dating app to me
was like i was like a conservative
parent watching all this i was like
these hips are gonna
turn my child into the devil like wait a
second
that's how i felt about dating gaps you
go on there as drew barrymore
well you can't you know what am i going
to do live
that's a that's a great way to start
anything
i'd like to tell a tip to most of the
guys on this app to stop being so
[ __ ] coy
and put your full name and don't make
your instagram account
private because why why would you do
that why would you
play koi like everybody's vulnerable in
this situation
respect women by telling the truth about
who you are
you're looking at the app you're
scrolling through and okay the first
thing you see is someone who you're
physically attracted to like
this guy doesn't look like a douche it's
usually the person inside that i'm drawn
to so this
facade of a dating app is really hard to
whittle through i'm not going to lie it
is
like you got to put on your [ __ ]
inspector clue so and sherlock holmes
[ __ ]
and i don't know why men play so coy i i
can't i can't even indulge it i'm just
like well
you won't tell me who you are so i'm
just gonna keep moving on
didn't you get stood up on one of those
dates yes
what happened true i was like getting
ready and on my way out the door
yeah and was like i can't it was a it
was a burger to carry bradshaw i can't
i'm sorry don't hate me i don't
except for his was just i can't i can't
how dare you that's rude you know what i
will say this to anyone out there
thank you you didn't waste my time
right and that's how everyone should
look at that situation
not boohoo what's wrong with me they
don't even know you
you